étranger
[Rires] c'est
avoir une chambre je peux faire des
blagues vraiment dégoûtantes à ce sujet
mais je vais m'abstenir mais ce gars
pour une raison quelconque
m'a ignoré pendant je ne sais pas sept
ans
et maintenant ça me donne un suçon
je  ne comprends pas, je pense que c'est ton eau de
Cologne de poisson, tout ce que je sais, c'est que j'ai mis de l'eau de
Cologne tom ford ce matin, donc
si tu veux que ton chat
te donne vraiment des baisers émouvants,
va pour le tom ford
d'accord, donc il est sous l'eau en ce moment
je  Je vais essayer de le soulever un
peu et de vous montrer à nouveau sa taille,
venez ici grand gars
et venez ici,
il est si grand et il est si lourd et c'est un
si bon garçon, regardez comme il est tolérant,
il est si bon
merci  tu es un grand mec tu es si gros et
lourd on continue juste à aller ici
regarde la queue sur lui la queue seule
est comme aussi grosse que moi
tu vas bien
maintenant il a définitivement gagné du
poulet pour tout ça
[Musique]
est
um
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
même si vous aimeriez que p  problème